- Just in the green room
of "Food Loves Tech."
- Hi, I'm Priscilla.
- How are you?
- Tech table.
- [Gary] Yes, my God, of course.
- How you doing?
- There's a lot of people
in loveless marriages.
It's an epidemic.
("Drive" by Noah Lopez)
There's you.
What are you?
- [DRock] I'm gonna to rock.
- Hey, how are you?
- Good to see you.
You too, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Hi, how's it goin'?
- [Gary] Hey, how are you?
How you feelin'?
- Good.
- Thank you so much.
3D pizza, huh?
DRock.
Awesome, thank you so much.
- [Woman] Yep.
- One thing that I think
is very fascinating,
is that I've never been to
a green room that's green.
- Hi, I'm Marcella.
- Hi, Marcella.
- I am such a huge fan.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Marcella] You are amazing.
You inspire me
everyday, seriously.
- Take a picture?
- Yeah, picture.
Sorry, I'm shaking.
- Don't worry, I'm so flattered.
- I'm so excited.
- Hey, man.
- [Gary] How are you?
- You're the fucking man.
- Thank you, buddy.
- Let me get a hug, man.
- You got it, brother.
- You have no idea, man.
- Thank you, man.
What's your name?
- [Kavon] Kavon.
- Kavon, a great pleasure.
- Great to meet you, man.
- How you doing?
I know.
- Dude, I'm so excited.
- Feel like it's a long time comin'.
- I feel like we gotta
trade some wine stories.
- I know, right?
- Dude, I'm so pumped
to finally meet you.
- Same, same.
- This is awesome.
- We did, and I just
reached in my bag,
and I realized like, "Oh,
I've got ham in my bag."
(laughs)
- [Gary] Bless you.
- [Woman] Smell it, smells really,
I don't know if you're
a vegan, are you?
- I love it, it smells phenomenal.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- You never know --
- It's great.
You never know when you need --
-When you're gonna
smell some bacon.
- How are you?
- Gary, I'm Zach.
- Zach, how are you?
- Pleasure to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- You're an inspiration.
- Thank you, my friend.
- Appreciate everything you do.
- Thank you so much.
- Before you, there was
no one that was
in the business sphere, that
showed himself this way --
- Yeah.
- Opened himself.
- It was inspiration to people --
- Yeah.
- To give that much vision.
Mark Cuban could be like the
only guy you could think of,
but he never opened
himself up, the way you do.
- Thank you, my friend.
- So, I think you're a visionary.
- [Gary] Thanks for being
here, thanks for saying hello.
- Thank you, Gary.
- Do we like it?
- I love it.
(laughs)
Awesome.
- Like 10 of 'em.
- We'll get people in here.
I gotcha.
- No, I know that.
I was gonna ask more like,
how does it feel to be
so attractive and so capable
about what you guys do?
(laughs)
Just curious, how humans
like that actually felt.
- I thought you woke up with the
same mentality, every morning?
- I do.
- Yeah.
- That my family's gonna
die, and that I'm grateful.
(laughs)
That's what I do,
I don't know how you roll.
- [Voiceover] Far seat for you, right?
(applauding and cheering)
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Voiceover] J-E-T-S, yes, yes, yes, yes!
- Yes.
That's how I like it.
I think technology exposes
who we actually are.
Right now, one of the favorite
things of so many of you,
is when you go out, and you
see a couple sitting there,
and they're both on the
phone the whole time,
you love to judge, don't you?
Right?
You love to say, "Hey, look.
"Look how sad that is."
For me, technology has done
that couple a great service,
because 20 years ago, that
same couple, sat at that
dinner table, and didn't say
a goddamn word to each other.
Now, they actually have
technology to escape into a world.
I actually look at couples
that sit there and look
at the phone the whole time,
as a major positive, not a negative.
Thank you.
(audience laughter)
It's true.
You know why he said that's a good one?
Because this man,
through his career,
saw unbelievable
amounts of couples
just sitting there,
not saying a word.
- When I'm with my wife,
I'm not looking at the phone.
- Well, 'cause you love her.
(audience laughter)
There's a lot of people
in loveless marriages.
It's an epidemic.
I think the biggest
trend right now
is fast casual,
premium fast casual.
I'm actually
completely fascinated,
that when the market
goes completely one way,
that actually, all the
opportunities in the other.
We all went social media open
with Facebook and Twitter,
the opportunity actually ended up
being Snapchat, of
disappearing it over here.
It was actually happening here.
I'm actually weirdly
fascinated, I'd love to get
your opinion on this, this
is bubbling up in my head.
As everything's going fast
casual, and the greatest chefs
of the world are trying
to produce, you know,
a different, very casual,
low-priced food alternatives,
I actually think super premium,
and quite super fancy,
is an open space again because
it's just a momentum game.
For me, when I see a market
going one way, it starts making
me understand that
there's an opportunity
in the other direction.
What was old,
becomes new, all the time.
So, weirdly, I think that
there's a pent up demand,
potentially, for super fancy,
experiences in big cities
like New York,
and San Francisco, and LA.
That's running through my mind.
Thank you so much, everyone.
Have a good night.
- Thank you.
(applauding and cheering)
- Can I take a pic?
- Selfie?
Yeah, for sure.
- Thank you so much.
- Awesome, really nice to meet you.
- [Woman] Nice to meet you.
- I really appreciated
your speech and everything.
It seemed very down to
earth, and very raw --
- Yeah.
- And real.
Which, you don't get it from
a lot of people you know.
- Exactly.
- No, honestly.
- Thank you.
- A lot of people
have this built up,
kind of, prepared speech--
- Yes.
- Like they're gonna
give word for word,
and you just kind
of went with the flow,
and said how it was.
A lot of the points
you made really true --
- Thank you.
- For this generation,
and this society --
- Thank you.
- And I really appreciate that.
- That's very nice of you.
- It's nice to meet you.
- Thank you so much.
It's nice to meet you, too.
- Hi, that's alright.
- Hi, I just wanted
to introduce myself.
My name is Sandra,
this is Alexis.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Hi, how are you?
- It was really wonderful,
everything you said.
I've been following
you for years --
- Thank you.
- [Woman] Hey, Gary.
- Hi.
- [Woman] Hey, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- I'm Alanna, from Tech Insider.
- How you doing?
- Hey, I'm doing great.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Alanna] How are you doing?
- I'm doing really well.
- [Man] How you been, man?
Good seeing you.
- [Gary] Thanks for comin'.
- [Woman] It's gonna be quick.
Pic with Nick, then we go.
(laughs)
- That's it, get out of here.
- [Gary] Love you, brother.
- Love you, too, man.
- [Gary] Thank you so
much for everything.
- You're the man.
- No, seriously.
- I do it for you, brother.
(kiss smacks)
- [Man] You're the best.
- I love these kind of events.
Vayner co-produced this with
Edible Magazine, New York City.
Really just excited, Jose Andres,
one of the great culinary
monsters, chefs, in the world.
Should be a fun fireside chat.
Just a good day, Friday.
Last couple Fridays, I've
been half-daying them,
and going out to, out with
family, and spending time,
so it's a nice grinder today,
which, I feel good about.
Did a one hour
operations meeting
with James Orsini, our
chief integration officer.
It was productive.
I really think
quick decision making,
and then reacting to the
reality is quite important.
Lately, a lot of my
executives are talking
about the speed of my decisions
Mainly, 'cause I'm not
crippled, and I have experience.
But, most importantly,
making decisions is the win.
Way too many people
watching this right now,
are crippled to make the call.
Adjust to your calls.
I had a really good session
with Arianna Huffington.
I was really glad that I was
able to clarify, kind of,
you know, it's what you
do when you're awake,
not how much sleep
you get, kind of thing.
It was fun to get Emily,
who I adore,
has been with the
company a long time,
to get that selfie, or
that picture with Arianna.
That was a lot of fun.
Do you want to
thank me personally?
- I first, don't understand
how this just happened.
I've been talking about
Arianna Huffington for, like,
literally months and
how much I wanna meet her,
and Gary was like, "Hey, Arianna,
"can you stop and meet Emily?
"I'll take a picture."
I was just like --
- Wow, what?
- It was just like, "Be
cool, please be cool,
"like, please don't
fangirl, this is it."
Yes.
I'm like within
tears of a verklempt.
- Did you text them the picture?
- Yeah, I was like, "Mom,
this is what happened."
- [Gary] Mom.
- Mom.
(laughs)
That's exactly what happened.
I said, "Yep, casually
meeting Arianna."
That's auntie.
Just me, cheesing with Arianna.
What?
- [Voiceover] Is she your idol?
- What?
Oh, okay.
Go through all
of my texts, sure.
Go all the way through.
- Just wanting to
make sure that you
and Jordan are not
conspiring too much.
(laughs)
It's just a good, great day.
Lot of meetings, lot of
operations stuff today.
Staffing, new client, which,
I don't think you got any of,
but timestamped it, into
like, boom, three hours.
A lot of stuff we can't show
you, like real client work.
It's funny, I talk about
being CEO of Vayner.
Obviously, there's a lot
of stuff we can't show you,
because of NDAs and client
stuff of that nature,
and I apologize not being
able to show every aspect.
Just not fully in
control of everything,
but lots of hours being put
into operations staffing.
- Hey, my name is Russ.
I've been at Vayner, on
the accounts strategy side,
for about four months now.
Just had a great chat with Gary,
just about goals, and dreams, and visions.
It's just amazing how, you know,
we get that access with
him, and get to sit down,
and kind of pick his
brain for a few minutes.
- If you're good enough, you'll win.
That's what it is.
So, like, I'm the extreme --
- [Russ] Right.
- And, thus, I should
have extreme results.
- [Russ] Right, which you, yeah.
- But like, not everybody
should have what I have.
- [Russ] Right.
- It's super okay to
make 450 a year,
fuckin' have the greatest
life of all time.
It's just, you have to make choices.
- [Russ] Yeah.
- It's just talent and hard work.
- [Russ] I still feel like
I'm figuring out, for me,
like, how far I want
to push that, you know?
- Yes, and it's gonna, by the way,
it's gonna change at 22 and 27 --
- [Russ] Right.
- And 29, and 31, and 40 --
- [Russ] Exactly,
priorities change, yeah.
- You're gonna
fall in love, (mumbles).
Something bad will happen
in your life, and fuck.
Something bad happened
to me tomorrow?
I don't give a shit about anything.
I don't want to buy the Jets,
I want my mom to get better.
- [Russ] Yeah, that's true, yeah.
- Do you understand'?
- [Russ] Yeah, I think
about that shit, too.
- Yeah, don't get crippled.
You have tons of, dude, I'm 18
fucking years older than you.
- [Russ] Yeah.
- You know,
you were four, 18 years ago.
- [Russ] Yeah.
(laughs)
- Can you wrap your
head around that?
I mean, listen,
I know I look old to you,
but I'm not that old,
you know what I mean?
It doesn't feel that crazy.
- [Russ] No, no, and I
think that's something --
- Do you know what I mean?
- As through our culture, though.
It's like we all feel that, kind of,
that's what you get
when you push that hard.
- It's equally fucking pushing
it, as it is being patient.
If you push from those two
extremes, you fucking make shit.
- [Russ] That's what I've
learned so much more recently.
I think I've been on one
extreme or the other.
- Everybody's on one
- [Russ] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's why the people that
push from both extremes win.
- [Russ] Yeah.
- That's why there are
so few people that win,
'cause it's much more fun to pull
from one side or the other.
- [Russ] Yeah.
- It's easy to talk about it.
You could fucking talk about it.
- [Russ] I'm a good talker.
- Me too.
(laughs)
Me too, but backing it up.
- [Russ] Yeah, exactly.
- But, you know what, you
can't even be judged yet.
I didn't even think about
judging myself at 22.
You have time.
Talk to me in four years,
when you'll still be a fucking kid.
- [Russ] Mhmmm.
(thud)
Damn.
(laughs)
I love it, man.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah, man, good luck to you.
Keep working.
I get a real, kind of,
360 full day.
I just love the action of
going to these meetings,
architecting, just architecting
at scale, so much fun.
Just enjoy the
marathon of this all.
To me, you know, I don't
know if this becomes
a non-descript episode, or
becomes one that gets a theme.
I know you're always
challenged by that, Staphon.
Big shout out to you, in the
last couple that you've edited.
That's right, Staphon's
edited the last two.
Maybe even three.
What I think I like
about today is, it's just
a good, old fashioned day,
of running businesses,
doing media opportunities,
doing event marketing,
interacting with my team.
Jesus, is this from you?
- [Voiceover] No.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Aww.
- [Voiceover] Uh, yeah.
- Your reaction was
terrible, get out of my face.
- [Voiceover] Oh, no.
I sent you an email today.
- You did. It was
very nice, thank you.
(laughs)
I have the best.
I mean, what CEO gets, like,
love letters all day long?
You guys never wrote
me a love letter.
Not one of the four of you.
This is something you should
look deep inside yourselves.
- [Tyler] Every
single day is my love --
- Everybody out.
What do you want?
Just good.
Good.
Love the action.
I'm addicted to the action.
The action is my oxygen.
I wouldn't trade it for the world.
- [ Woman] You too.
(kiss smack)
- [Gary] Bye, guys.
Have a great day.
- Bye.
- [Gary] Goodbye, good night.
Alright, signing off.
Headed to spend some
time with the fam,
and get some sleep,
like all of you should.
Times Square, baby.
(instrumental hip hop music)